six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go next
to our caller from the three one five
area code caller from three one five go
ahead uh hello this is Jay from upstate
New York hey Jay what's going on I just
wanted to get your input on the turnout
for the youth vote for the midterms this
year how do you feel about the
percentage I believe it's roughly 30
percent of Minnesota turns out to vote
well listen it's better I can't seem to
express my frustration without
expletives so I wanted to get a more
articulate view from you yeah I mean
okay so historically we know that older
voters tend to vote more until they get
so old that it's like hard to vote but
then absentee ballots help that and but
basically we know that younger voters
are not voting in the same proportions
as older voters middle age older voters
adults whatever young adults vote vote
the least in midterms
the the turnout is particularly low in
general and also among young voters if
only you know there's this catch-22
where it's not even a catch-22 it's more
of a vicious circle young voters often
don't participate because they don't
understand how their participation will
influence the system in ways that will
change circumstances for them they're
like my vote doesn't matter it won't do
anything
well if young voters voted at 60%
instead of 30% which that's still 40% of
them not voting right if they could just
have 60% of young voters voting all of a
sudden you would immediately matter
because you're deciding elections but
they're choosing not to do that and it's
this depressing disappointing vicious
circle so yeah I'm always disappointed
by the pathetically low voter turnout
young people especially should be voting
because they actually have a chance of
steering the ship now before they end up
taking over control of a society that
they played no role in directing to
begin with because ultimately young
people are going to be in charge and
wouldn't
wouldn't they prefer to be in charge of
a system they helped shape they're not
doing that by not by not voting and it's
embarrassing um if I could have one
quick follow-up what do we do to
motivate them that we're not already
doing they from the young voters I talk
to they don't see how voting will make a
difference they often have this approach
which is not unique to them but it does
seem to exist a lot in young voters of
listen no matter who I vote for more or
less it's like I'm still gonna come out
of college with huge debt if they're
still in college or I'm still gonna have
my huge college debt I'm still gonna be
working a job that doesn't really pay a
good wage they just don't understand how
their votes impact their future and I
think the younger people are the easier
it is to ignore activities that don't
have an immediate gain or an immediate
impact so I think we need to be better
at communicating how number one their
vote does matter and number two how it
matters in ways that even if they don't
immediately see change as a result very
soon there will be changes like if we
got truly progressive representation in
the House Senate and White House within
eight years you would see pretty
significant change in a lot of areas
health care it could change dramatically
education could eight years isn't that
crazy for an 18 year old to think about
I hope anyway as opposed to a 92 year
old sure thank you yeah thanks for the
call really a prettier not very very
important important issue young people
Mandy got a vote today's program was
made possible in part by Blink accom /
Pakman I love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the David
Pakman show
I'm sure you'll love politics and
learning and what blinka says take the
best and most popular non-fiction books
they condense them into 15-minute
audiobooks that you can listen to in one
sitting and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many book
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
7 day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up